in this video you're going to learn how
to solve polynomial
inequalities algebraically and we're
going to use the number line to do that
so basically what you want to do here is
you want to
first get everything on one side of the
inequality and set it to 0.
so we're going to go through three
examples see if you can do some of these
on your own but the first thing
we want to do like i said is get
everything on one side set it to zero
and then we want to factor it as much as
we can
so what i notice here is already zero on
one side but this is what we call a
difference of
two squares so 4x squared is a perfect
square because 2x times 2x
25 is a perfect square because 5 times
itself
one of these is positive one of these is
negative if you need to review factoring
check out my
factoring video where i talk about how
to factor all different types and how to
recognize them and
i show a nice tree diagram so that you
can make the decision about what to do
first second
third but now we want to do is we want
to set
each of these factors each of these
groups to zero
so you can make a little mini equation
or you can do the work in your head
if you're good at that so here i'm going
to subtract 5 from both sides
and i'm going to divide both sides by 2
so we get x equals negative 5
halves here i'm going to add 5 to both
sides and divide both sides by 2
so we get x equals positive 5 halves
then what you want to do is you want to
go to the number line
and you want to plot these on the number
line from lowest to highest so the
smallest on the left
and the larger one on the right and
because it's greater than or equal to
zero
equal to means this is going to be a
closed circle it's going to be it's
going to include that point
so right at negative 5 halves or
positive 5 halves that's going to make
the left side
equal to zero but now we want to see
what points
are going to make it greater than zero
greater than zero is another way of
saying making it
positive right so we're going to do
something called sine analysis and what
you do is you just pick a point
in each of these intervals so for
example maybe negative 3 over here
if i put negative 3 in for x i get
negative 6
plus 5 is negative 1 but i'm just going
to call that negative
okay negative 3 times 2 is negative 6
minus 5 is negative 11. that's also
negative
a negative times a negative is a
positive so i'm just going to put a plus
sign there
so any point in this interval okay all
the way to negative infinity it's going
to be positive
let's pick a point in this interval how
about 0 if i put 0 in
2 times 0 is 0 plus 5 is 5. that's
positive
2 times 0 is 0 minus 5 that's negative a
positive times a negative
is a negative so i'll put a minus sign
or a negative there
if we pick a point over here to say like
positive 3 2 times 3 is 6 plus 5 is 11
that's positive
2 times 3 is 6 minus 5 is 1 that's also
positive
a positive times a positive is a
positive
so now we can see we want to know where
it's greater than or equal to zero
so it's going to be when x is less than
or equal to negative five halves
okay or now in math remember or means
union it means both x is greater than or
equal to
5 halves you're going to be to the right
of this point or to the
left of this point or it'll equal 0
right at those points now if you
know interval notation we're starting
over here at negative infinity this is
positive infinity so it's going to be
from negative infinity
all the way to five halves including
five halves so i use the square bracket
you can't reach infinity that's going to
be the parenthesis that's like an open
on this side union okay union's like or
that's going to be this
and this both these regions five halves
okay so we're using the square bracket
because it includes five halves all the
way to
positive infinity can never reach
infinity that's open okay with the
parenthesis
so interval notation or inequality
notation whichever way your teacher
prefers now you might be saying mario
you know i don't really understand what
all this is about right
and here's and i understand see the
thing is if we were to graph this in not
one dimension but in two dimensions like
on an x y
coordinate plane okay like see this is
zero here this is your origin
you would have a parabola that would
look something like
this okay roughly and so what you can
see is
it's basically saying like where is the
parabola equal to 0
that's right here at these x-intercepts
or greater than 0 meaning above the
x-axis
and that's going to be when you're to
the left here see how you're above the
x-axis over here
you're below the x-axis right but what
we're doing is just a quicker way just
analyzing it in one dimension okay on
the number line as opposed to going
through all the trouble of graphing the
whole graph and seeing where it's above
the x-axis or equal to
you know right on the x-axis let's look
at another example see if you can do
this one
so for number two we have x squared
minus x is less than 12.
okay so remember step number one get
everything on one side
and set it to zero right
okay step number two factor
as much as you can so what multiplies to
negative 12 but adds to negative one
that's negative four and positive three
you can check your work by foiling this
out
and make sure it comes out to the
original there
step number three we set each factor
to zero so we make a little mini
equation
add four to both sides subtract three x
equals negative three and then
step number what do we have step number
four we plotted on the number line from
lowest to highest so
from negative three four okay you don't
want to reverse it not make sure the
lowest number always the highest number
and you could when you factor you could
have more than uh
two solutions here you could have three
four five however many
but now in this one see how it's less
than zero but not
equal to zero so that means that these
are actually going to be
open okay because we wanna know where
it's going to be less than zero meaning
below the x-axis not on the x-axis if we
were to graph this in two dimensions
so now we're on step number five i
believe we're going to do the sine
analysis
okay and we're going to pick some test
points in each interval to see if it
where it is negative because we want to
know where it's less than zero so pick
easy numbers a good number here might be
like negative four
negative four minus four is negative
eight i'll just say negative negative
four plus three is negative one that's
negative
see how these two parentheses are right
next to each other they're multiplied
together
a negative times a negative is a
positive if we pick
let's say zero zero minus four is
negative four that's negative
zero plus three is positive three that's
positive a negative times a positive is
a negative
if we pick a number over here say like
10 10 minus 4 is 6 that's positive 10
plus 3 is 13 that's positive and a
positive times a positive is a positive
but we're looking for where the graph is
less than zero
meaning you know below the x-axis or
where it's negative so that's going to
be right here
and you can write this as a compound
inequality x is greater than negative
three
and less than four okay that's one
option or if you want to use the
interval notation
from negative three to four you can
check out my video about the difference
between
inequality notation and interval
notation if this is uh challenging for
you just look that up on youtube
now if you want to understand this at a
deeper level remember
this is a parabola see how this a value
is positive one that means this graph is
going to be
opening up if it was like a negative it
would be opening down so we know the
graph looks like that
and we're saying where is it less than
zero meaning where is it below
the x-axis and the
y-axis would be somewhere here but you
were looking for where it's below not
equal to because it was less than but
not equal to zero
and you got it so third example see if
you can do this one on your own
this one's a little bit more challenging
i try to start easy and get
progressively more challenging you've
probably noticed that if you've been
watching my videos
and i also wanted to say if you like my
teaching style
you know i've got courses i've got
algebra 1 algebra 2
geometry act math sat math so those are
for sale check those out
i'll have a link in the description but
what do you notice about
this one here we've got four terms right
so we could try
factoring by grouping you know you're
factoring by grouping
you group the first two terms put a plus
sign there and you group the
last two terms okay then you factor out
the greatest common factor so in this
case it's x
squared okay so i divided these both by
x squared
this one because it starts with a
negative i'm going to factor out a
negative one out of both of these guys
see like that so positive 1 divided by
negative 1 is negative 1.
and now because we have an x minus 1 in
common in both of
this group here and this group here we
can factor out that x minus 1
and we're left with x squared minus 1.
but this is a difference of two squares
we can factor that further
x plus 1x minus 1 and bring down the x
minus 1. now you notice that there's an
x minus 1 and an x minus
1. we can condense this and write this
as x minus 1 the quantity squared
okay but now when we set these groups
equal to 0 we get
negative 1 and positive 1.
we want it to be greater than zero so
that means that these are going to be
open okay if it was greater than or
equal to zero then these would be closed
because at these points that's where it
crosses the x-axis that's where it's
equal to zero
now we just have to do our test points
i'm gonna pick negative 2
0 and positive 2. so if i do negative 2
i get negative 2 plus 1 is negative 1.
negative 2 minus 1 is negative 3 but
negative 3 squared is positive 9
right so negative times a positive is a
negative if i do zero
zero plus one is positive one that's
positive and
one thing to notice here is whenever you
square something it's always going to be
positive so we have a positive times a
positive which is a positive
and if we do two we get three which is
positive two minus one is one
one squared is positive and a positive
times a positive is a positive
now you're probably saying mario this is
a little bit unusual right because
you've got a positive and a positive
over here they seem to always alternate
and you're probably wondering well why
is that well if we were to graph this
in two dimensions like in the x y
coordinate plane
notice this leading coefficient is
positive that means it's going to be
going
up to the right like this and it's an
odd degree which means it's going to be
going down to the left like this so this
graph is actually going to look
something like this
and it's going to bounce right off 1.
and you can check that by graphing this
on your graphing calculator
but notice how it's below the x-axis
here see how we got negative
it's above the x-axis here we got
positive and it's also above the x-axis
here
positive so if we want to write this in
inequality notation we want it to be
greater than zero so where it's positive
so we want
this interval right here as well as this
interval right here
okay going to infinity but we don't want
this point 1. so i'm going to say
x is greater than negative 1 and less
than 1
okay or remember or means union it means
both in math
x is greater than 1. if we want to do
the interval notation we start on the
left we work our way from left to right
negative one to one notice these are
parentheses they're open means it
doesn't include the
it does not include the endpoints union
okay u for union
uh 1 2 positive infinity so again open
because it
doesn't include one infinity we can't
really reach infinity so inequality or
interval notation either one
uh great job i'll see you in the next
video